[Upbeat music begins and plays during the
video]
[Dr. Dina Demner-Fushman] When people need
information, what they really like is to ask
a question and get a really good comprehensive
answer, and also know that the answer is true
and correct.
When I started my independent clinician career,
I had lots of questions but I was sometimes
not even sure if I'm getting the right answer.
Question answering is this system has to understand
the question, what the question is about,
and why is it asked.
When the answer is found, it's usually not
a single answer.
It's parts of the answer in different places.
It's multiple answers.
So all of that then needs to be condensed
into one comprehensive answer with evidence
to where the answer came from.
So that's the focus of my research.
On the surface, very similar questions asked
by clinicians, and by the public, should be
answered very differently.
Different deep learning systems are needed
to find the answers to the same question asked
by two different people.
[Silence]
[Upbeat music starts again]
The long-term goal is one entry point to all
the NLM resources.
It doesn't matter who the person is and how
they ask their question or look for information.
We should be able to recognize what the person
needs and provide it.
There is no one, other than NLM, who is specifically
dedicated to biomedical information retrieval
-- biomedical question answering.
Although industry seems that they are doing
that kind of research as well, it is not their
main focus.
Whereas, we keep people focused on what really
matters for health and advancing medicine.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]